one of joe biden's first actions as
president-elect has been to form a covid
task force and encourage
everyone in america to wear a mask
unfortunately a lot of americans say
this policy impedes their personal
freedom
luckily there's a product for those who
don't want to be forced to wear a mask
take a look are you tired of being
forced to wear a mask just to enter
stores bars and restaurants
if you're fed up with wearing a piece of
cloth on your face because of a tiny
little global pandemic we
have a solution introducing fake masks
fake masks are high quality counterfeit
face coverings that are completely
indistinguishable from real masks
they're sure to get you into anywhere
that requires a face covering
take a look at this comparison of one of
those freedom destroying real masks with
one of our fake masks
you can't even tell the difference hey
nice mask fool them for the low low
price of 350
you'll never have to wear a mask again
and the best part is they're as
medically effective as real masks
so how are these any different from
order now to receive a 50
discount on our patented fake face
shields
fake masks they're different we
promise